Congresswoman Nancy Mace
called out a witness at a House
hearing yesterday.
It was focused on
anti-democratic, extremist group
the threat that they pose to dem
Mace, as you know,
is a Republican congresswoman
from South Carolina.
She started her time asking the
a few yes or no questions like t
Do you believe
that rhetoric targeting official
with violence
for carrying out
their constitutional duties
is a threat to democracy?
Mr. Ward.
Mr. Siegel.
Yes.
Yes, yes.
Then Congresswoman Mace turned
her attention to all 100
Carballo and LGBTQ rights activi
an instructor at Harvard Law,
and some of her past tweets
only a few weeks
after the attempted attack
on a Supreme Court justice on Ju
One of the witnesses, Alejandro
Caraballo, tweeted out the follo
in response to a decision on abo
overturning Roe v Wade.
And I'll quote directly from the
The six justices
who overturned Roe
should never know peace again.
It is our civic duty
to a cost them
every time they're in public,
they are pariahs.
Since women don't have their rig
these justices should never have
a peaceful moment in public agai
I know something about being acc
The night of January 5th,
I was physically accosted
on the streets of DC
in Navy Yard by constituent of m
I fervently blamed rhetoric, rhe
on social media,
rhetoric at public events
for being physically accosted.
I carry a gun everywhere I go
when I am in my district and I'm
because I know personally
that rhetoric has consequences.
I've had my car keyed.
I've had my house spray painted.
I had someone trespass in my hou
as recently as August.
I've been doxed on social media
about where I live.
So my last question today of MS.
Caraballo,
do you stand by these comments,
this kind of rhetoric on social
And do you believe it's
a threat to democracy?
Thank you, Representative,
for the opportunity
to clarify
and provide context to my tweets
I have a question in the astrona
Do you believe
your rhetoric is a threat to dem
when you're calling it a cost,
a branch of government,
the Supreme Court?
I don't believe that's a correct
characterization, you might say.
Did you not tweet that?
What happened to the speaker's h
is every member's worst nightmar
So it's clear to me
that we have to call it
the threats to our democracy
emanating from wherever they com
whether it's the right or the le
Quite a grilling.
Yeah,
I think she's
listen, we've all had to deal wi
Some of us more than others,
she obviously is awful with what
the Masons had to deal with.
But I think it's right.
The rhetoric has to be toned dow
I hope Elon Musk is listening.
I hope the people who run social
I hope they're listening to this
and everyone should have
the same energy Republicans.
They have the same energy about
if it happens on their side,
Democrats should have the same e
if it happens on their side as w
because it has to be toned down.
What you end up with people
getting hurt or January six.
Then you saw like with Justice K
she was talking about this
Trayvon outside his home. Yeah,